[Musik]
Tag Freunde was geht ab euer
lieblingsvlogger mal wieder back on
track wir fahren nach
Amsterdam also wir sind jetzt in der
Stadt angekommen und haben wirklich mal
wieder das beste Wetter aus Deutschland
mitgebracht hat übrigens so wenig Ahnung
vom Essen dass er sich einfach Ketchup
zu seiner Pizza bestellt hat ich habe
noch nie in einem Laden genau eine
Rechnung über 100 € gesehen der Jackpot
hier ist so tot einfach nur 120
Millionen Amsterdam so eine brutalchöne
Stadt
ne einfach aus wie Weihnachten es ist
auch bald Weihnachten und von den
Temperaturen ist doch quasi schon
Weihnachten das ist die Bahn das ist
Tobi das sind Leute die mein Blog
gequatscht haben hallo okay nicht Hall
das da oben ist einfach durchgezogen
eine Wohnung oder Hotel keine Ahnung
aber das da vorne ist einfach so dein
wohn mal dann geht's einfach da so lang
UPS wir sind gerade auf irgend so einer
Party wo man am Eingang einfach Sticker
für seine Kamera bekommt s dass man
keine Videos in im Laden macht also ich
kann so bei berghein und so ein Scheiß
verstehen aber wir sind auf so einer
ganz normalen Party also ich respektiere
das natürlich selbstverständlich sind
die Regeln aber guckt euch mal dieses
Klo an wir waren jetzt gerade unten in
so einem Privatkino und haben einfach
irgendeinen neuen Wodka vorgestellt
bekommen der genauso geschmeckt hat jer
andere auch so oder
so was ist das jetzt für eine Toilette
das schön nein ich nein indirekte
Beleuchtung ist das Schönste was es bei
Häusern gibt diese Dinger da einfach
indirekt Haus beleuchten guck euch
generell diese Stadt an wie schön das
aussieht ignoriert Tobi aber so das da
vorne das geb einfach aus wie
hockw das hier ist einfach so der Smart
von Holland das steht an jeder Ecke was
ein Foto ja
warte Bruder
diese Stadt lebt guckt euch das an
überall sind Leute laufen rum machen
jetzt
irgendwas was den
hier der pinkelt einfach ins
Meer das geht nicht ich hasse das alle
Leute mit den ich unterwegs sind sind
asozial also mlerweile ist Moment
erreicht wo
wir leicht
hinterfragen ob wir mit Captain Blaubär
eher in die See stechen würden oder
rechts
links oder ob wir mit Captain Balou auf
toll grüne Crew gehen
würden peace Leute was geht ab ich bin
Marvin ich bin
kvin ne Schmatzer
ja ist nicht gerade rot okay alles gut
Alter geht schon wieder rot grün Glück
gehabt ich habe alle worauf warten wir
eigentlich wenn du in der englischen Bar
Tobis Namen sagst kriegst du immer zwei
Bier
[Musik]
Tobias Bruder danke Tobias Hal versucht
noch immer unser Taxi es steht angeblich
Zitat es muss es muss ja genau hier
stehen höre ich seit 20 Minuten
mitgeteilt ich glaube der komplette Vlog
besteht daraus dass Luca in seinem
Zustand gerade durch Amsterdam le wie
heißt der Ort leite pline
läuft pline läuft und ein taxiuch das
sind alles Freunde von mir hier die auch
er hier mein Abi sie sucht Taxi alles
klar Bruder ich auch ja ja ist da vorne
genau da
vorne Taxi ist da vorne ja ja das nicht
unser Taxi wir ste aus wir anderes
Kennzeichen
[Musik]
okay ich weiß nicht wie wir das
hingekriegt haben aber wir sind im
bet
ja warte jetzt
komm
warte warte warte warte ja hast es ja
woll wir noch mal und ich sind auf jeden
Fall okay und ich sind jetzt auf jeden
Fall zurück auf dem Hotelzimmer
angekommen l daumen hoch wenn es euch
gefallen
hat
wir hab noch zwei Tage vor
uns ich kann nichts men ich denke ihr
merkt schon dass wir noch leicht
verklatscht und verkatert von gestern
sind meine Damen und Herren deswegen
müssen wir natürlich gleich eine Menge
Wasser trinken den das hilft ja
bekanntlich am besten gegen einen Kater
und apropos Wasser sponsort a ab
freundlicherweise das heutige Video denn
a ab aromatisiert das Wasser nur durch
die Luft die machen sich nämlich die
Tatsache zu Nutze dass wir 80% über
unsere Nase
schmecken
diger
krank junge durch das Saugen an dem
silikonaufsatz entsteht ein Sog der
einerseits das Wasser in den Mund bringt
allerdings auch die Luft zirkulieren
lässt und durch den duftpot dann einen
Geschmack erzeugt das was ich eh ab zu
nutzen macht hat in der Wissenschaft
sogar wirklich einen Namen das heißt
nämlich retronasales riechen also quasi
dass der Geschmack im Rachenraum vom
Riechzentrum so wahrgenommen wird aber
eigentlich gar nicht vorhanden ist du
trinkst eigentlich nur Wasser es gibt
ultra viele Geschmacksrichtungen also
Ihr Hab da wirklich querb alles am Start
von Cola über vi bisin zu Basilikum
Zitrone ich habe h aktuell white Peach
mit am Start und ihr könnt sogar mit dem
Code Laser 10% sparen im Webshop bis zum
6.11 und danach gibt's auch noch
verschiedenste Bundles danke schön
ab kann mir irgendjemand von unten in
den Kommentaren erklären warum
Coffeeshops coffees Shops heißen und
nicht irgendwie kifferledäden weil die
haben ja OBV nichts mit Kaffee zu tun
top frühstücksladen in Amsterdam meine
Damen und Herren winis um euch mal hier
so ein paar Tipps zu geben Jungs wie
gefällt euch bisher ist mir auch
[Musik]
egal
also was ich an Amsterdam bisher am
meisten mag ist wirklich das Wetter wir
haben die ganze Zeit nur Sonnenschein
alle Idioten hier mit Burger Bier Cola
Chicken Wings und ich wieder der einzige
schön mit einem
Salat bester Burgerladen übrigens in
ganz Amsterdam the
Bcher wir waren gerade shoppen
oh Golden Retriever
süß wir waren ger shoen ich habe mir
eine Hose gekauft und nutze jetzt
eigentlich nur als
Regenschirm top ah moin sind jetzt im
Stadion von Ajax Amsterdam angekommen
weil hier irgendwie das größte
Musikfestival ich habe keine Ahnung ich
hab wirklich keine Ahnung sagen war
nicht nein früher war es mein größter
Traum Gabelstapler Fahrer zu
werden ich habe dann irgendwann
aufgehört weil ich so ein Video gesehen
habe wie so ein Ding so eine Taube
überfahren hat und dann hat mir die
Taube irgendwie leid willst was sagen in
meinem Blog bitte willst du was sagen in
meinem Blog ja klar ich will immer
eigentlich was
sagen ich weiß jetzt wiederum nicht wie
das passieren konnte aber ich stehe
jetzt direkt beim DJ ich meine ich sag
auch hier nicht nein Genie wie ich in
der
Schule nicht hi man ich laufe auf wisst
was ich nie verstanden habe das sind ja
alles Kaugummis auf dem Boden das ist
das sind ja alles Kaugummis wie können
sich Kaugummis so krank in den Boden
einprägen
na ja ich kann gut beim
Thema von diesem ganzen Festival hier
sind 60.000 Leute in dem ganzen Stadion
und nur durch den sind wir irgendwie
reingekommen und sind jetzt überhaupt
überhaupt überhaupt ja 13 davonings
ehrlich gesagt bin ich gerade ein
bisschen na wie sagt man auf Deutsch
konventionell ich habe keine Ahnung was
das heißt Jungs obwohl wir seit einer
Viertelstunde warten ich muss kurz für
den Blog zu tun als ob VI ler W damit es
krasser ist
okay 14 Tage später Freunde wir haben 3
Stunden geschlafen sind gerade
ausgecheckt im Hotel sind oder haben
gerade aus haben ausgecheckt ne haben
ausgecheckt wir haben 3 Stunden
[Musik]
geschlafen s mittlerweile wieder in Köln
angekommen und jetzt tatsächlich auf dem
Weg hier zum Stadion Köln Derby der Typ
ist Gladbach Fan he das ist ein Kollege
von
[Musik]
mir fC
[Applaus]
Köln
ich bin jetzt wieder zu Hause und habe
die letzten vier Stunden dieses Video
hier geschnitten diesen Blog und ich
kann nur sagen meiner Ansicht nach ist
es ja geisteskrank was ich hier alles
erlebt habe an diesem Wochenende ich
weiß es ist in vogs von anderen Youtuber
wahrscheinlich das was die innerhalb von
einer Stunde erleben aber ich mache halt
sonst nicht so viel ich bin ziemlich vi
zu Hause ehrlich gesagt desen war das
für mich schon echt sehr sehr cooles
Wochenende wenn euch der VOG auch
gefallen hat könnt ihr gerne meinen
Kanal abonnieren da könnt ihr einfach
auf den smy drauf klicken oder euch hier
den letzten Blog anschauen und noch mal
ein riesiges Dankeschön an erhab dass
sie das heutige Video freundlicherweise
unterstützt haben bis zum 6.11 könnt ihr
noch mit dem Code Laser 10% sparen Kuss
wir hören uns sehen uns riechen uns
keine Ahnung haut rein ne oder nicht
reinhauen wer dann halt W dann W
verletzen würd aber ich hau es rein
tschüss